jouez vous montrez de trois toilettes de
personnes on a trouvé je vous jure que
c'est vrai s'élèverait toilettes
regardez regardez on va jouer entre nous
et c'est tout et à qui elle appartient
d'accord on pas un premier toilettes
regarde pour mes toilettes
si vous voulez manier vous le cul avant
tout clarifier tétouan à la bonne
réponse
[Applaudissements]
l'arrière quand tu es
quels sont les meilleurs que nous
j'imagine dans les 12 coups de midi avec
jean luc reichmann
il met la question et la réponse en
dessous mais c'est vraiment des coups
mal de sachets qui s'annonce est
quelqu'un ici le cas là ouais c'est le
cas aussi arrive à les regarder mais les
toilettes des toilettes sont très petit
et il a remis son diplôme tes diplômes
et donne de quoi aller tous mes diplômes
dans les toilettes à monaco n'a pas
beaucoup faire parler du lourd en face à
un mur enfin avec un nabab rigueur de
pas compte quand même quoi c'est quoi
tel quoi c'est quoi des diplômes alors
sa celulle en hausse et le prédire fort
qu'on m'a remis en 2011 c'est à pour le
meilleur livre politique de l'année mais
en dessous c'est je suis chevalier des
arts et lettres n'ont pas assez ou
ferait un certain qu'il en soit je suis
relié des arts les lettres est pareil ça
fait 10 ans de ces orchidées jacquet
chevalier si non la trace de loup n'a
pas non c'est vrai qu'il faut le
demander
non on n'est jamais très bien tu disais
que ça n'allait
il ya d'autres trucs ça regarde et on
part dans les toilettes une personne qui
aime la déchire as tu regardé à c'est
quelqu'un qui aime les livres la jeune
coûte la libye j'arrive de dinsheim
galériste regrouper ses les toilettes de
valérie bénaïm regardez il ya des
bouquins ah bon et ouais ben haim à mon
avis elle passe beaucoup de temps aux
toilettes on dirait une salle d'attenté
c'est là il ya la belle a le bec
yakhi akli je vois le houellebecq
beigbeder des wallmart la select c'est
la même place sauf à regarder alors on
va regarder ça c'est une autre personne
autour de la table ou s'il vous plaît ça
qui ça géraldine et moi j'ai un débat
vous avez été chiche
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'à lui aussi avec un bon
tir a dit oui un shoot ces lieux c'est
si on fait quoi ouais je dois mais
j'adore les samoa j'adore les gens se
taisent
c'est qui ça c'est justement de ces kiss
a le projet celui-ci je peux parler au
nom balle à côté de vous
[Rires]
et c'est pas c'est à vous ça on a trois
toilettes une seule qui ferment et moi
j'aime j'adore les dessins c'est un
dessin de mode et recaro quant à la
fêtarde ans elle affiche du film à cela
d'un dessin de norman rockwell et une
pub bourgeois c'est tous des affichistes
que j'adore aller voilà un indice du 3
mars au 2 avril 77 ya vercingétorix
papier c'est du passé
c'est la seule qui sait sur des sites
[Applaudissements]
ça va on a compris à et les toilettes du
chroniqueur suivantes sont à qui ça qui
as a ses propres contrats mal à personne
jean-michel taisez vous plaît vous voyez
bien regarder je vais montrer vous lui
comment il voit c'est que les riches ils
sont si les toilettes de cassé mais non
les gars ça dure on voit qu'à de
l'oseille on voit qu'elle n'osait c'est
celui qui a pris le plus aux lgv non
mais montre moi tes toilettes je te
dirai qui tu es au sol et ben moi je
n'en ai pas gêner toilettes turques
oui c'est vrai oui oui on y voit une
belle robinetterie benjamin il a une
très belle au lieu d'être email ou dans
les pattes
écoutez en tout cas bravo pour les
gradins